morning everyone and bear with us while
we get our live stream started for our
Lincoln audience
just just a moment
and I'm told we're having a problem with
the live stream so I'm just going to go
ahead and get the session started
um
sharing privilege Mike so we
at the beginning
okay
and my name is Stuart Creek I'm a
marketing manager here at simply learn
I'm here with Mike Ash the director of
the Caltech Center for technology
management education and we're here to
talk about
the Caltech data science boot camp
your way to get into a data science
career
to six months
let's go ahead Mike yeah hi everybody
good morning
um you can see my screen I think yes so
okay
um
uh Welcome to our webinar in the data
science uh boot camp that Caltech has
with simply learn and we've been
Partners but simply learned for uh for a
few years now and teamed with them
because they've got a really great
learning platform for technical
application
you're going to learn a lot in this and
understand your different choices in in
jumping into a professional development
program so I've been here at uh Caltech
for about five years I come out of
management consulting uh
background for 20 plus years with
pricewaterhouse Deloitte IBM
um we'll say kind of back in the old
days when most of all the analysis that
we're doing is either at Excel and SAS
and SPSS now there are so many more
tools to uh to use so we have a
professional development and Executive
Education here at Caltech we work with
plan organizations
technology companies government
uh new startups all in engineering and
people kind of on the edge of Technology
creating uh really great products and
platforms for the world
in these boot camps these are open
enrollment for the public and I help
create those and manage those including
this one in the series of boot camps
that we have in software engineering
let's simply learn
um what Stuart and I are going to talk
to you about today and and Stern are we
going to have a live uh
look at the platform
we have someone else joining us today or
is it just you and me I was just you and
me today
okay so we're going to learn a little
bit about you all uh we'll talk about
the program uh breakdown about what the
offering is uh set some expectations
around the the timing and the rigor
that's involved
and then we'll talk about some of the
other benefits that uh that come along
with enrolling in this program including
that the assistance with uh with job
search
and getting ready to either change a
career jump into a new career and answer
any questions
along the way okay
so let's talk a little bit about
careers and in data science so
you know
not only has this been popular and
everyone already knows that but the
amount of data that as output is is
staggering I mean we can't even really
wrap your head around it
um 175 zettabytes is
more than I could imagine a lot of that
is a video a lot of that is an
unstructured text a lot of that is in
structured data and we all need ways of
understanding what that is what are the
patterns how do we use this whether
we're using it for science where we're
using it for business or other
applications
um it's a a huge field and maybe some of
you on this webinar today are looking at
changing your career to move into the
field
um if you're already a technologist and
you want to expand what you're doing and
we'll talk a little bit about how this
might be relevant for you
um some of the many roles across data
science that this program is going to be
relevant for
um include people who want to be the
data scientist that want to be a better
analyst
architect information
architect Technologies
applying machine learning and then
business intelligence and visualization
to commercial problems
uh perhaps you want to get into
statistics uh whether you know for
research
or business
um and and just being an overall kind of
analytics engineer and that is more than
just the Technologies but it's the
communications it's being able to
understand what is this data telling us
what does it mean and and whether or not
we should act on it
uh and so these are many roles that are
available in almost any kind of company
and if you're pursuing these kinds of
roles there are a number of skills that
we need to excel in and one boot camp is
not going to give you everything you
can't be an expert just by finishing
but
in a comprehensive program like ours
that you're going to cover many of these
things and you're going to know a
substantial
portion in order to land that job or
operate it successfully in the role
right so it you already need to be kind
of clever and come in with an
understanding of math and and basic
statistics but what you're going to get
into here to build skills is more around
what is it what kind of data do we need
to solve problems how do I get that
how do I manipulate that data
um how do I get it ready to perform
certain analyzes
is it something that we can apply
machine learning to
how do we train that machine learning
how do we package all that together and
whether we're scripting or coding or
using python
we'll have to get into those things
um and so having that kind of broader
analytical thinking and critical
thinking you also need to bring
your skills and the scientific method
having a hypothesis finding the data and
and
solving those problems proving or
disproving those hypotheses
whether it's for business experiments or
research or other
we're going to work on making you
a better analytical thinker
so let's get a sense of who's in in the
audience a little bit
um Stuart we want to take us through
this
got a cushioner sure and the poll is
obliged for the people in the WebEx uh
audience if you're on our streaming
audiences
please do put your answers in the chat
we're curious to know what has stopped
you from enrolling in a program of this
type up-to-date
um
is it because you can't find a
comprehensive program that talks about
the skills that Mike just covered does
it
because you don't think the program will
give you the Practical experience that
you can then point to when you're
looking for a job because
you're not comfortable doing the
traditional self-learning through videos
or is it because you can't find the time
in your schedule
and here are the results from our
audience today
and after the audience says you can't
find a
program that gives you practical
experience that you can point to
and then
about a quarter of the audience answered
each of the other responses
well
let's go on and talk about how this
program addresses these issues yeah
[Music]
the
what
there are a couple things you need to
know about the these kinds of programs
um and we're gonna
uh just briefly mention also an AI and
machine learning bootcamp
so
one is there there's a lot of
information that's out there there are a
lot of free intro to data science
internet of python intro to
statistics
data analytics
those are out there they're great
resources some come from universities
some come from Caltech some come from
Google and Amazon they are all good and
you should consume those and and watch
videos and do those things what you
don't get out of it that was a part of
the in that poll is how do I apply that
in a business situation
how do I run a project that needs that
and that's where these boot camps are
going to
set set you apart from just consuming
that
available other free resources
um that are good we want you to go see
those what we want you to do in in our
boot camps they're much more
experiential
and so how do you apply those
tools how do you apply that thinking and
work on projects So within the the data
science boot camps
these are really comprehensive programs
um you know they're they're six seven we
have some that are nine months uh
they're a little open-ended because you
need time to work on uh projects and
demonstrate your learning this is how I
approach this problem
this is how I
capture and document this is how I share
with other people like on a team or an
employer
whether the people that on on GitHub or
somewhere to for people to be able to
access
um it's going to be Hands-On and it's
going to be iterative and there's going
to be guidance and that's that's a big
part that guidance comes from the
instructors that are in the program it
comes from the master class
instructors from Caltech but it also
comes from peer-to-peer learning
and that's why that that's how this is
different than doing something solo
um
two important points this is a
comprehensive program and when that says
five to ten hours a week a lot of that
is concentrated on the weekends
there's programs or
intensive
there's a commitment to work on
Saturdays and Sundays four hours each
because that's when the live sessions
are where you're going to apply
and interact with instructors and and
teams
so there's some learning on your own
along the way look at something and we
deploy like a flipped classroom model
watch videos do some of the learning
practice come in on Saturdays and
Sundays live online and work through
these things watch additional lectures
um and and get into the active labs and
actually
do things and iterate and prototype and
get that feedback that's what those are
for but at seven months all weekend so
you need to be able to commit to
something like that so this is
um not a program where you can kind of
fly through and get a certificate at the
end and not really do anything that's
not what this is uh these are graded
graded the
projects and assignments along the way
and there's and there's multiple
so it requires attention requires some
commitment and it requires
uh thinking up front about your schedule
the kind of commitments you need to be
able to make both to family and work and
others so we really needed to put that
out there
second is
and the reason why the AI machine
learning bootcamp is
uh we've found a number of the people
who come to the webinars to understand
the programs to have different
backgrounds they live in different
places they have different exposure to
um
education what they did in the past what
their strengths are now the strengths
that they want to build
if you are already
pretty uh experienced in in coding and
let's say Python and and statistics and
understanding regression
the data science boot camp may be
uh two novice for you
you might want to be looking at the AI
and machine learning bootcamp which
Builds on those skills and then you're
going to get into more deep learning
and recursive networks and tensorflow
and other things and other applications
where you're training
um Algos
if you are a little bit more beginner a
little more
I'd say low intermediate
um if if you don't have a a fairly
strong background with math
um and science they you may need to do
some things before you enroll in the
program we just want to be clear
um
not only does it take commitment but it
takes understanding so you can really
jump in and there's content that's
available to you
to either remediate or
kind of give you a jump start
but if you are fairly Advanced I'd I'd
be looking at the AI and machine
learning bootcamp the stuff we'll talk
about in this program and on this
webinar is more about the data science
bootcamp you will essentially hear many
of the same kind of thing so feel free
to hang with us
so at the end of of seven months it the
program doesn't just stop on Wednesday
the 15th it's when you finish your major
Capstone project and that's kind of at
the end the culmination of
um of what you've learned that you work
on a project you code that it works it's
available for others to see it produces
results and that's a Capstone when you
get that done and you've passed all
these other assignments and
you can elect to do some certifications
along the way that are separate
then you can earn your certificate from
Caltech
there are a number of labs which said
there are a number of other
certifications that you can do along the
way you can participate in IBM's
hackathons which are pretty cool
also they're asking anything sessions
they're the master classes which are
monthly sessions
and also in uh at the end you can
earn what are called continuing
education credits CEUs these are similar
to pdus if you're already a project
manager and understand how that works
CEUs are important to justify
employers covering your tuition so if
you're thinking about this program and
this is not a uh trivial uh tuition fee
for the program you you will want
employers to help you out with that so
these programs often qualify for tuition
reimbursement
um
so just know that there's continuing
education credits that are available to
you when you're done with the program we
also would invite you to a private
LinkedIn Community we'll do some other
things there's a graduation event that
we do a reporter among all the simply
learned programs the boot camps that we
have
and yeah we get these awesome documents
if you don't know uh what is uh Caltech
I'd have it confused with another school
in California
the California Institute of Technology
has been around since 1891.
um one of one of the uh original real
science and engineering institutes it's
a small University
um I might not even call it a university
because it's not like we have lots of
colleges underneath it
um
Caltech is a PhD machine there are only
900 or so undergrads 1300 grad students
most people come here
to uh in academic because they want to
get into research they want a PhD many
go into commercial Ventures and and
being entrepreneurs
a number of spin outs have have come out
of
Caltech
important more
the invention of
Xerox very large
um dlsi chips
DNA sequencing all kinds of things we
have a couple smart people around here
um and
just the environment here is is amazing
what we want to do is try to bring that
into these programs and and give you
access to some of the thinking here and
we're in Pasadena California but the
boot camps are online
um okay so it's live remote there's no
commitment to coming to campus
they're also we don't have a path to a
degree program so if you're looking for
a master's or PhD in this program is
going to give you an entry into that we
don't really have a path for
matriculation our group ctme is all
non-degree programs certificate programs
for working professionals
uh so I I love that we have a
partnership with IBM uh as I said
earlier I'm uh I'm an ibmer former ibmer
I think once you're you've been in IBM
you're you're always an IBM room
um so I already mentioned the the kind
of things that uh
we have with the hackathon and being
able to do other other certifications
but it's this is a really nice ad to to
this program I think it brings a lot of
value
okay
um
to be eligible for for this particular
program uh like I said earlier uh if
you've got experience in programming and
math do you understand a little bit of
linear algebra
uh the data science boot camp would
probably be good for you if you have a
better understanding of linear algebra
machine learning might be good for you
or if you have a lot more coding
experience
um we will get into python we will get
into other libraries we'll get into uh
a little bit of job in this
um
we need you to be
um this is for adult learners
you need to
have completed some education and this
is
geared for business and also for science
if you have two or more years of work
experience
that relevancy will be very very helpful
because you're going to be working on
business business problems in the
projects that you'll be working on so we
really want to see people like that but
um
but other than those prerequisites in a
screening process your uh you will go
through
um it's an open enrollment program
so let's understand how much experience
you have
um Stuart
yeah it's a pretty straightforward
question so we'll leave it open for
about 20 seconds
um
but what
what experience do you have it doesn't
have to be the experience you have in
technology or any particular field but
there's how much work experience do you
have in the
in the world of employment
close the poll in about three seconds
here is the result
it's a interesting like you said before
Mike interesting bimodal distribution we
have uh 40 of our audience
have less than two years of work
experience
and an equal number have more than 10.
so yeah
very interesting uh
so well the
um the program can
work for you and if
a couple years of experience is going to
be helpful
um people who have been in
uh you know we we could maybe ask this
poll a different way is how much uh
technical experience folks have but I'm
not going to do that now
uh just if if you are an experienced
developer maybe analytics data science
is a little new to you then this is
going to be perfect if you have a lot of
experience and uh
you didn't need to be on a fast track to
getting more I take a look at the
machine learning bootcamp
which is also around seven months
um
we'll talk a little bit about how the
program is going to prepare you
um
Stuart I can talk about a couple of
these things and then well maybe I'll
hand it over yeah I'll go ahead and
describe what what's going on with this
slide so the
the
learning environment is a online
learning management system as Mike
mentioned it's delivered entirely online
and
gives you the tools to manage your
curriculum you'll be able to see all of
the courses that comprise the boot camp
you'll see how far you've gotten in or
accomplishment which courses you've
completed which is the next one coming
up be able to look at your calendar
classes
the get reminders for your live virtual
classroom classes each weekend
again as Mike said take those online but
you do those
four hours each Saturday and Sunday and
those are your
opportunities to interact directly with
live instructors to ask them the
questions directly to take again
taken through the concepts and
techniques live and the instructor can
ask you to submit your answers to
questions or your code Snippets
um so it also gives you the chance to
interact with your peers in the class
uh you are given the ability to take
your tests and exercises and Labs online
there is a online development
environment
we're within the learning management
system you can do all of the necessary
coding on a virtual machine
um so that you
don't really require to
load anything onto your own system other
than for your own
offline experimentation
the Capstone project is Mike described
is vital because that will take
everything you've learned in all of the
courses up to the culmination of the
program
and let you apply all those skills to an
industry-based problem
and your solution will be yours to keep
in your GitHub portfolio and
go off to employers
again as I mentioned the system keeps
track of your progress it will send you
reminders to stay on track with your
course progression any assignments that
are due and it will also let you unlock
certificates you learned that you earn
along the way both unlocking each course
in the program and then unlocking the
IBM certificates that you earned and
finally unlocking the final
program completion certificate once
you've successfully completed your
Capstone so
all along this way you have support
tools you have ability to contact your
instructor
to ask for help on a 24 7 basis from
Sports staff both for the technical
issues with the with the platform if
there are any but also with the subject
matter questions
if you're working on something at three
o'clock in the morning and you come
across a question or a
blocker that keeps you from progressing
you can ask that question
get help through the support system but
also through your peers on a Community
chat board
so all of those things are available to
you all the reference materials
um all of the self learning videos that
supplement the program
are all through this one learning
management system
accessible to you
both are your laptop or desktop device
but also much of it is suitable for
using on your mobile device so you can
use it anywhere at any time
that's
the learning environment
Michael Scott go on to the next
and the program curriculum
builds in a stepwise fashion so each of
these blocks is the course
uh or it starts with the bottom block
the orientation session tells you what
to expect when to expect it how to use
learning management system you move into
statistic Essentials
dude then build on that and introduce
our programming
our language you then
add python
is one of the main programming tools for
data science
after the basic introduction to python
you go deeper into Advanced Techniques
using python
data science applications
you get exposed to machine learning
and you
get exposed to Tableau which is all
important because the purpose of data
science is to communicate insights from
data to people who will use those
insights guide business or policy
decisions
and visualization is one of the
strongest tools that you have for
telling the story of the data to people
who are uh
Tableau is an important part of the
classroom or the course assignments
uh
culminates in the Capstone project along
the way you have the option of taking
the electives that are included at no
extra cost
they're up to you based on your
commitment and level of interest and
availability so you can learn about the
Excel for business analytics
SQL database Training Power bi which is
another form of
analysis tool from Microsoft you can
get farther into deep learning
and finally you have the master classes
through Caltech and IBM that are Mike
said monthly and allow you to interact
with
ctme instructors IBM professionals
so all of that is structured for you the
learning management system takes you
through it in this in that
stepwise fashion
helps you build a skill upon skill and
strength strength upon strength to get
to the final
certification
so along the way you're going to learn a
number of different tools you'll be
exposed to those I think those are on
the next slide Mike oh yeah
um
so
one of the interesting things about
building your resume at the end of this
program is that when you list these
various tools skills platforms libraries
you won't be just listing them as
buzzwords you'll be listing them as
things you have actually
learn to use and applied in your
coursework
the
you'll use various of these along the
way in different courses and then you'll
use some combination of your choosing to
do your Capstone project you'll be able
to claim on your resume
your experience with these skills and
you'll be able to demonstrate that as
well so next slide we talk about well
let me make a comment for sure
absolutely um so but
a question usually comes up along the
way when we're doing the webinars so
what's the difference between the data
science bootcamp and data analytics
bootcamps in the data analytics bootcamp
is definitely more business related uh
focuses a lot on SQL
statistics various business statistics
Finance
and Accounting and the use of Tableau in
business intelligence
data science you're going to be getting
into more of the tools that you see here
and and the associated libraries
um so it like I said python
major coding tool sci-fi numpy as part
of the the libraries for that
um
we probably should have Matlab if we
don't have that
um you know we're going to get into our
um which is also uh very relevant in
science and engineering
um but the
you're going to be in these more
advanced tools and
um
like we said it's a little bit broader
than just business statistics and and
and Analysis business analysis
um so that's a good way to think about
what's the difference between the data
science and and our data analytics boot
Council
yeah and finally
um the Capstone project we keep coming
back to that because this is something
that can actually we've had experience
in our programs people reporting back
that
um just based on showing the Capstone
project during an interview they were
able to get a job offer so the reason
this is important is because it allows
you to show that you have mastered all
of the material and skills in the
courses
um not just through a final exam but
through an actual Hands-On practical
application of those skills
um
or given the option of several different
industry aligned real world type
problems you pick one that you want to
solve you work on that for several weeks
with your
instructor meeting with you weekly as a
mentor to make sure you're not going
down any
dead ends or getting stuck in any rabbit
holes but at the end of that process you
then submit your projects for evaluation
that becomes essentially your your final
exam in the course
and it also becomes a permanent part of
your portfolio to take with you into the
future to show to potential employers
and give them
practical example of your experience
with data science
we find that
this is one of the
best parts of how we've structured the
program for you
that's critical yeah
we developed the program with with
similar and about
I guess maybe four years ago I've Been
instrumental since the beginning and uh
our executive director in ctme
uh Rick Hefner aerospace engineer for 40
plus years also on the software
side as well as
physical engineering that is the overall
advisor on this who's also been through
the content developed it with
with simply learn and we have Master
Class instructors with
um
a large consulting company experience
and and delivering to clients who will
talk about their experiences in data
science and and others
yeah so
really great really great program
uh learner outcomes
yeah so you'd like to mention the fact
that you we bring in people into these
programs from
many different areas
not just people coming in from
technology companies or information
technology or software development
companies but also
from banking from financial institutions
from manufacturing from Aerospace from
every
industry because
data science
now affects and it's used in every
industry so you get exposed to various
people are coming in from other
backgrounds and other
job opportunities you can talk to you
about what's going on at their companies
and always a nice thing to be able to
rub elbows with other people in industry
and get that kind of
cross-learning that type but um
the next slide we'll talk about
actual
services that we provide you'll be able
to look at the
website for the for our program and see
some testimonial from people who have
taken it
we'll also
Mike said it doesn't end
when the Capstone gets graded you get
your certificate it's not a handshake
and goodbye it is
um six months of additional Services
provided through simply learning our
partner job
pardon me
um Tony think yes I was going to say
because job assist is what we call the
program
um so what talent Inc does is it gives
you access to
resume building interview prep
and job boards but in and above that
over and above that we have expert
webinars and career events that simply
runs on an ongoing basis for free to our
alumni to continue learning about
different topics in the industry
trends and we also
emphasize that the projects that you do
in the boot camp themselves are part of
your
portfolio for your job search so let's
go to the next slide yeah one other
important comment here I don't know if
if we mention those at the outset that
the data science boot camp and then ml
boot camps these are for us audiences I
think we could but that means North
America
um but the uh we're really focused on on
U.S Learners here
um and with the job assistance it does
not mean job placement there are no
guarantee of jobs
um you know because that's that as Tom
Cruise said it's up to the the person in
the Box
um it's up to you as being able to
um
make those uh those connections and win
that uh consideration
yeah that's correct
um
so as I mentioned
jobs Services through Talent Inc include
access to a premium job portal
gives you a bit of exclusive access to
some of those job listings
um the more important aspects I think
are the resume rewriting because
resumes take on a different importance
today because of the automated tracking
systems AI Bots that are used by
employers so your resume has to serve
two purposes one it has to get through
that automated screening and secondly it
has to get be attractive to the humans
who see it afterward
yeah this resume review and rewrite
service allows you to
get both of those accomplished so it
gives you a chance to take your
information about your experience and
your skills work with a professional put
it into a format that both attractive to
Human
interviewers or evaluators but also is
in a suitable format
pass through that first AI screening
event
when somebody puts in a job description
into one of those systems you're able to
get that passed through and match up
with it in the 101 interview service
allows you to practice both technical
skills interviews as well as the soft
skills and management team fit
interviews that are going to be part of
anybody's job search even if you're
doing a job search internally for a
promotion you'll still have to go
through different levels of interviews
and interview preparations very
important part of that
so as uh Mike just previewed we have the
different webinars and educational
sessions
um
we're doing today a webinar that is
talking about one of our programs
but what simply owner also offers is a
set of webinars during the week that
talk about
um
industry trends
we're career opportunities are going to
be What new technologies are coming out
some mini horses
one hour lessons on how to apply
different Technologies
perspectives on how to conduct a job
search how to develop your career so all
of these things are there to support you
in your career development going forward
and this is at no extra cost that this
is a lifetime
benefit there's no expiration on this
one
and we talk about the projects to
demonstrate your skills
and you have the Capstone project that
you take with you you also have the
other projects you've done along the way
so you can pull into a
your portfolio and pull up
different projects that you've done for
the different courses so that you can
demonstrate yes I do have
skills in different libraries of python
doing analysis through that and here's a
project that I did the this is important
especially for people who are have
limited um
direct experience that they're going to
be able to cite from job experience
people who or people who are moving into
a brand new field
always great to be able to say yes I
have done work in this area here are the
projects I've done
and evaluate my work so
with that
I think we move on to the last question
before our q a
and
we'll pull up the question pretty
straightforward
and basically are you interested based
on what you've heard today in enrolling
a data science bootcamp
let's leave it open for another 10
seconds
maybe if you're interested in the
machine learning boot camp and instead
you might want to put that in the in the
chat for us yeah I would suggest
um
because the way to get started is to
email us at us ask us at simplylearn.net
you'll be able to ask directly about
either of the programs
and let me show you what the result is
the about 90 of the people who responded
said yes they are interested great we
can talk to you now about how to get
how to do that the enrollment steps
um enrollment steps are pretty
straightforward you mail us as I
mentioned to ask us simplylearn.net
and we then
evaluate your qualifications
there will be an aptitude test for
programming
programming skills in
aptitude for statistics and then
if you pass those you will get a offer
of admission
learning consultant will let you know
then you'll start the program and the
next slide shows when the next course
date is
next course date is
January 7 2023
and you'll have a introductory session
before that this is what the date the
active classes start
Porsche fee is a flat eight thousand
dollars
it can be financed zero interest
financing for as low as 704 dollars a
month
as Mike correctly pointed out that your
employer
may offer tuition reimbursement for this
some employers will pay for the course
up front more more frequently
pay for the course and then apply for
reimbursement from your employer when
the course is complete
that is completely up to your employer
so you need to check with your HR or
Learning and Development
staff
about their policies but again to get
started email us at ask us it's simple
that
I will put into the chat right now that
email address
if I find the chat
and you can move on to the questions and
answers now Mike yeah
I'm gonna
pick back the sharing privilege
and we can just address those questions
that have come in and they're still
coming in
um
but I've asked I'm from a non-it
background how do you switch into data
science
I'm sorry I was reading the chat uh yeah
the first one is a question from this
I'm from a non-it background so how do
you switch
the data science from a non-it
background
well they're uh
there are a lot of roles and and jobs
that people have that aren't I.T but
they deal with data
um and so if you're coming from that
there's no
there's an easy way
if you are
brand new coming in cold
then I would look at
some
remediation and and learning because
it's what you want to be able to to get
into
um
go back to math
early statistics understanding reasoning
um
getting into some of the Python classes
so let's say this program starts in in
January you're interested in it
didn't double down during November
December and try to start some of that
um if if it is an interesting career
choice if you were and you're just not
prepared
go through some of those foundational
courses
uh and spend time doing that until you
feel that you're ready to
um then take that aptitude test I'm not
an aptitude test but uh
uh you know basically it's the
um that the test on on statistics for
screening
um go go through that and then
then apply and enroll when you're ready
we can point you to a number of courses
that are either uh from Simply learn uh
Caltech has some free ones that are
online but those are more advanced
machine learning uh that are available
um but also be happy to recommend other
other other content and and like I
mentioned at the first there are a
number of things that are available from
other folks like IBM Amazon Google other
schools
uh start with those look at extension
um offerings
says I have a fair knowledge of python
and image processing
and does this program support Advanced
image processing and I'm I would go on a
limb and say that you'd want to take the
a i m l boot camp
yeah
image processing and and
deep learning and and um
and those that networks the even I I
take a heart
a hard look at the curriculum for that
because you may already be doing some
advanced work that even that program may
not work for you
um in the ml program they'll get into
other aspects of cognitive Computing so
not just computer vision but also
natural language processing spend a lot
of time on that as well
um
uh text and other
ml applications
but to
we might need to do some
um
some some digging to see where where
you're going to overlap significantly
with
um Lamont has a whole series of
questions which basically are
would be the perfect
frequently asked questions for the
course and probably we'll feed that back
to our webpage but uh first you ask how
many hours of class time and study time
are recommended uh eight hours of class
time each week study time
based on your uh abilities and that type
of thing but usually anywhere from half
hour to an hour a day or a bit more
depending on if you're doing an advanced
um
project like you're during the time
you're doing your
stepson project you're going to be
spending a bit more time than that
um
but employer pays for the boot camp
through grant funding how does the
tuition payment get handled that would
be between you and your employer if you
arrange for your employer to pay the
tuition payment directly
uh that's great usually what happens is
that you would pay the tuition and then
apply for a rebate from your employer
there there are centers that um and and
you can email me directly
um
Caltech has relationships with some
um aerospace companies where the
admissions has to be
you have to register through Caltech not
through simply learn and and so we can
we can handle that for you
and if you
email Mike directly if you want to put
in your chat in the chat window Mike
your email address
um
or if you mentioned that to the ask us
at simpleline.net people they can
blending counselor can also put in touch
with him but um
is this a program a VA approved boot
camp where the GI bill can be used uh
not that I'm aware but are you aware of
that Mike
um yeah we I've had the the question a
couple times this week
um the center for technology and
management education in Caltech is not
set up for benefits for the GI program
um
there I wasn't sure if uh their tuition
breaks that simply learn provides
um you would ask the uh through the
learning counselor yeah have people ask
simply learn when they talk to the the
folks online
I'd also give that same advice to Wayne
who asks if there are discounts for
people who have completed other
uh uh simply learning programs or boot
camps um
can ask that question of the learning
counselors
um Lamont asked about the instructors
what percent of the classes are taught
by Caltech ctme instructors versus
others
I will generally tell you that the
classes are taught by industry uh
professionals
people who have worked in are working in
the industry
and then the Caltech master classes ctme
master classes are taught by instructors
from Caltech ctme
yeah but um your course instructors are
people drawn from industry who
are
vetted through Caltech and simply learn
and know their material and
we maintain a very aggressive program of
here evaluation in
learner evaluations of our instructors
um so we make sure that they have high
scores
ratings from the people who take the
classes because
um
we have no interest in
having a substandard
instructor
um causing disappointment for our
Learners we want everybody to succeed
and master the material so very very
picky about that
what are the hardware and software
requirements for the boot camp
generally you're going to want to do
this on a
laptop or desktop computer doesn't have
to be the highest end
the main requirement is that you can
access the learning management system
through your web browser so your
internet connection is probably more
important than the quality of the
machine itself there are times when your
instructor may say you can download this
tool or access this tool from another
source and play with it on your own
in which case you probably do want to
have
a fairly recent model but not a
requirement particular for this course
um are there any attendance requirements
in terms of on-campus or physical
attendance no this is entirely delivered
online there's an attendance requirement
meaning that you have to show up to your
virtual classes on the weekends a
certain percentage of the time
understanding that that's not possible a
hundred percent of the time the classes
are recorded and so if you miss one or
two you'll be able to go back and
watch the session catch up on the
material there is a minimum requirement
however in terms of percentage of
classes you attend live
it's a doobie aware of that and prepared
to make that commitment
and
um
Mike you might be asked to be able to
answer this better what are the days of
the week and times of the day that the
class live classes are held in
life of a specific cost yeah oh um
early morning
um
like eight to twelve
eight to twelve Saturday and Sunday each
day and um
as I mentioned the
classes are recorded So if you are away
for a weekend or doing something else
um you can catch up on that week's
courses uh
primary difference of this boot camp to
the AI on ML machine I I would
offer you uh
to
email ask us at simplylearn.net ask a
little bit about that there are also
some on our website you'll be able to
see the
both of the course descriptions and
download the syllabus for each one and
be able to make that comparison yeah the
easiest way to answer that also is the
um
you'll spend a lot more time in other
forms of
and other libraries
um and other forms of Applied AI like we
were talking about computer vision
earlier in NLP
you'll have a lot more of that in that
program than in this one
um how much Python and Jenga are covered
in this program versus uh AI machine
learning I think Van Gogh is mainly
covered in the AI and machine learning
program python is covered in both yeah
um how many students are in each cohort
usually good question
we try for about 35 or so anymore
because of the questions
it uh slows the the class down so this
is not a mooc there are not hundreds of
people in the class a cohort has about
35 or so
um
you know that that stick with the
program
that enter the program and and
that you could change to another cohort
uh potentially but we try to keep it
smaller for productive learning
okay
and Kathy asks
not ready for the January 7th class one
of the future cohorts I would say you
asked that of the people at askus
simply.net they have the first schedule
information the one that's listed on our
website is just the the next upcoming
one but these happen about how
frequently do new cohorts start so it
ranges so
um
some of the boot camps are
are start once a month
some have two or three because of the
volume of people that are in it so
cloud.com Computing bootcamp
regularly runs about three above three
top three startups a month
um and so if you are not ready for for
January and that's good
um there will be another start probably
in the February or in March
um so I think at like a baseline level
uh expect monthly starts the um the
specifics uh days uh for or the dates
when it's gonna
um
uh enrollment starts with the
orientation program but maybe the class
doesn't start for another month and so
sometimes especially close to the
holiday like this
the team that you talked to uh simply
learned we'll have those dates for you
okay
um
civil asks an interesting question uh so
it was a nurse who's 65 years old who
has been self-taught in coding and tools
like SAS and Excel
and wants to know if this program would
be suitable
so I'm I'm sorry I'm
there's not an impediment for age right
I mean ages well no and uh it's a great
question one I just uh love it and then
self-taught in SAS and excels is good
too
um
we just published a uh a video
testimonial from a gentleman who
is I think he is also 65 that just took
the machine learning AI boot camp and
talked about why he's doing it he's
already late in his career
um wanting to do something else
um yeah you can you can do it you're you
know you're either still working or
you're just interested
um we don't we don't stop you
um we love lifelong learners but I love
the the tenacity at a pick up these
kinds of skills
um and and putting it to work in
clinical research so yeah
uh and I think the last question you
have time for I know that there are
other questions and I apologize but we
uh are at our hour so I want to take the
last question from Meng who talks about
the support that
is offered when you run into problems
with projects and being able to say that
you have several different support
Avenues through the learning management
system
one is you can email your instructor of
course instructors sleep so they aren't
available 24 7 however our support staff
is we have both support staff for
subject matter so you can ask questions
about data science from those people as
well as asking questions about gee
something isn't working uh the way it's
supposed to in my learning management
system where I can't access this
particular course recording of that type
of thing they can help you with those
technical difficulties you can also
reach out to your peers through the
community board on the lending
management system so you can say gee I'm
working on this project who else is in
the class is having trouble with this
and get that kind of support
the all of those are available plus your
instructors will post resources along
with each course in terms of
codes that they've demonstrated or
readings or
self-paced videos that they want you to
watch either before or after a given
class but all of that is there on the
learning management system so with that
I'm going to um
move on and one last question for the
audience
all the way down to
very last question
so for those of you who said you are
interested in enrolling
how soon would you like to do it Kathy
already told us that the the upcoming
cohort is too soon for her so
to know
the rest of you when would you like to
begin with something you see yourself
doing in that
media cohort the
three months down the road six months
more than that
we always say that if it's something
that's going to change your life and
your career for the for the better
always consider doing it sooner than
later
we'll leave this open for another few
seconds three two
one
and the poll result
I think if I'm reading this correctly uh
36 percent of the audience about a third
are interested in starting immediately
um which is great because we haven't
given you the date for that next cohort
and then people
are mainly interested in starting
somewhere in the three months out or six
months out range
um so again
um wherever you are on the scale please
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
they'll be able to help you with
scheduling what um cohort is going to be
available for you giving you an idea of
when to get re-contacted if you're
looking at something out in the future
but we're of course getting you started
right away with that I want to thank
Mike very much for being here today and
taking us through the program
and I want to thank everyone else here
for taking time out of your day View
spend with us on this program and we
hope that we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with Caltech ctme
yeah thank you everybody and thank you
Wayne Ryan who's taken another boot camp
and and wants to join this after he
takes a little break uh so thanks
everybody uh if you have questions
uh send them to us and
we appreciate your time okay and I have
put the uh ask us to Simply learn uh
addressing the chat along with the
course page
do feel free to contact Mike uh also
email me at Stuart at simply Stuart
Creek at simpler.net it's the address
that came with you your invitation to
the WebEx
so
again thank you all for being here and
that concludes our webinar for today
bye everybody bye